hello good morning good afternoon good
evening good middle of the night if
you'd like wherever you are in the world
and welcome to Psy track your Sci-Fi TV
and movie channel
we are going to be talking
the Stargate movie again really
really
um before we get started as well can I
just say that I will not tolerate people
disagreeing with me any more on this
channel
right I will block you I will
put you down whatever it requires damn
it
I'm gonna have to disagree with that so
yeah
that's a good way to start the
conversation now disagreement is gold
disagreement is what makes the world go
around that and money and love and other
stuff but they'll correlates degree so
we are going to talk about this target
movie we're gonna
um try and comment it from a slightly
different attack than we did in
yesterday's live chat which was actually
brilliant from with Mac from the
MacGyver podcast
um but yeah that's what we're gonna do
so um I'm gonna run the credit and we're
gonna get stuck into it and I'm gonna
explain to you why I'm right and you are
all right
[Music]
so before we get stuck in how are you
gentlemen
doing good doing well
doing well
considered putting eye drops in a minute
ago and then realized that's probably
not the best thing to do before a stream
you look sleepy
aloha's Quest David B all the regulars
are in this with this mortise knock too
how are you all right so
basically I did a video in the week
hello Quest
um
and I talked about how a Jason Momoa
movie was my idea of the perfect way to
start the franchise
and now well I will explain to you why
I'm writing you're both wrong in a
minute
um because I'm thinking about it wrong
because I think you're both a bit stupid
now
I'm with you is I going too far is that
too far
it's matches matches the idiot well we
knew that
um yeah no I got too far with that so
easily you bet I I think there are many
reasons why it makes sense but
we're going to discuss today the movie
that we would love to see so we'll think
of a couple of options for that the
movie that I think would make the most
money my thinking and the movie that I
actually think we're going to get
because we'll talk about some of the
rumors we've heard and some of the
um
I like that idea David I disagree would
say 90 of the time but not this time
about Ronan
90 of the time that's a lot better
that's a lot
right so every time you say we say we
want Stargate you're disagreeing with
that is that what you're saying that's
probably the 10 he likes
every idea we toss out there is just
like yeah
that's the idea about the Stargates next
to each other who disagrees about that
probably
um but baby hey look that's absolutely
cool anyway I'm absolutely fine like I'm
married I'm used to being disagree with
so it's it's absolutely fine I'm used to
being told I'm an idiot on a daily basis
I've got teenage boys for the love of
God I'm used to it so right first of all
let's just go with right Matt you don't
want a Ronin movie you think that's a
terrible idea why before I explain to
you wrong
I don't I I
haven't said I don't want one
I just don't think it's good to
kick-start the Stargate franchise I have
three things I've written down as to why
and you can we can I'll say them if you
want right now and you can dissect them
if you want but these are these we'll
then go into the movie we think we're
gonna get and blah blah blah so let's
let's focus on the road and think first
and get out the way and okay for the
reasons I don't want it to be the first
thing we get is because right the first
thing I've put is Jason Momo was not the
heart of Stargate he's a great character
but not who I think of when I think of
Stargate and the reason I've written
that is because
although he's a great character you
don't when you think of Stargate you
think of people like Jack O'Neill
Samantha Carter Daniel Jackson and all
of the villains that come with you don't
really think of Rowan yes he was a great
character
but
he's not he wasn't the character that
would lead
he wasn't the character that I would put
at the Forefront
Jason Momoa side ignore the fact that
he's played by Jason Momoa ignore that
fact yeah I mean I would say even SGA
you think about Shepherds you think
about Rodney probably
yep
exactly
so that's that's reason one
reason two is Road index movie would be
vastly different to what we actually
want which is more Adventures through
the gate because a ronin Dex movie would
probably focus on him being a runner and
it would probably be so different to
just Stargate in general
it wouldn't feel like Stargate and if
you're trying to Kickstart a franchise
you're not gonna you wouldn't kick
it's like for example
the Star Wars franchise if they
kick-started it with the Mandalorian yes
it's still Star Wars
but it's it it wouldn't I don't think it
would have worked you need
you need to have seen everything
beforehand
to to be in that Universe kind of thing
can I interject do do you mind because I
actually think that's the exact opposite
I would have thousand percent of
preferred the Mandalorian Mandalorian
literally brought Star Wars back after
it had fallen from high Graces and them
trying to do a big movie is the thing
that screwed up doing one big movie and
not having an actual plan laid out
screwed things up what's the most
successful IP that's that's ever been is
Marvel they didn't start it with some
giant Avengers movie they didn't try to
bring all these characters and they
didn't have the rights to a bunch of
characters sure but they didn't start it
out with Avengers or X-Men or anything
like that one it was one of the almost a
background character initially people
were like they're gonna come back with
Iron Man really D to your character I
think we need to keep it simple one of
my favorite sayings I say it all the
time I try to live by this keep it
simple stupid and honestly that fits in
this so well keep it simple don't over
if they overdo it I think it might Force
awakens us and I I mean I know some
people still like to force awakens I it
the root of the problems for the SQL
issue SQL Trilogy issues which led to
problems for years with Star Wars until
something like the Mandalorian came
along and it was just that simple little
thing that just just it it didn't
hurt anything else in the world in the
Star Wars Universe it didn't take away
from anything and it just brought you
into a little piece of piece of stuff
that you didn't necessarily know what
time period it was you knew the general
time period but you didn't know the
exact year so you're trying to figure
that out you're trying to figure out how
these characters are going to interact
with other characters within the world
and then in a simple way formulaic and
to a degree but that's kind of where
stargate's always done well I think
keeping it simple like that would be
wait I do have a counter for that no
contact wait wait wait wait tell us the
third thing and then let's let's go
through them one by one and and split
them up so what was your third reason so
the third reason is he is he has a big
name and I think that could hurt
Stargate
so I put Jason my work onto a certain
gravitas and expectations Target was
never about high-end action scenes it
was just about the people to places and
the adventure
and also I'd like to add on to that that
when Stargate was on the air they never
had
massive names with the exceptional Dean
Anderson he was a big TV name yeah okay
yeah
right okay so well I'm having him
inwards I think
create that expectation if it didn't do
well
it could hurt the franchise massively
yeah it increases in the sense that it
doesn't do well for what they're
expecting not with us I mean for what
they're expecting because of Jason Momo
being in it well let's go through one at
a time then but so
um he was never a central character and
I 100 agree with you and Aristotle you
think I think it's completely irrelevant
though because
out of for what two things I'm gonna say
I'm thinking of this from an executive
point of view and if I'm spending 150
million dollars on it
and I'm also gonna we'll talk about this
in a minute but I think there's a
traditional way of doing these things
and maybe the last 10 years has changed
but traditionally if you want a big
sci-fi franchise to kick off you have to
have a movie and you have to have an
A-list star and the only A-list star
we've got this connected to Stargate in
any way is Jason Momoa
so that's that would be my first
argument I know that the Ronin decks
character isn't big but it's irrelevant
because Jason Momoa has become
um
Harris what do you think
no I I'm with you there that makes sense
uh and and then again I think the one
thing that
we're coming from a Stargate perspective
I don't think we're thinking about this
in like a general perspective as well
Jason MO is really not that big of an
actor he said he's he's done Aquaman
that's a billion dollar movie that's
huge
look at every other single movie he's
ever done name one Jason Momoa movie
besides Aquaman like a Jason Momoa movie
Raven was brilliant okay I mean there
are smaller ones and I do love yeah that
was more almost like an indie movie
really I mean it was every single one of
anything he's ever done besides Aquaman
is small he and he likes that he's a
genre actor I don't think getting him
back is very hard I don't think he's
going to be nearly as expensive as
people think he is or would be
um I don't think he would necessarily be
the biggest of draws either and we'll
see with Aquaman 2 of course
Aquaman just happened to be a very James
Wan was the director of Aquaman was on a
high coming off of The Conjuring stuff
all of the Insidious stuff uh malignant
and a few other things so a lot of
people horror fans went to go see
Aquaman which is a huge sub base of film
people that
people forget about all the time they're
the ones going to see movies more
frequently than any other genre of fans
in in the world so that helped a lot
with Aquaman I don't know if that helps
necessarily moving forward with
everything else so I think MOA actually
is perfect in the sense where he's he is
an a-lister but he's not so big of an
a-lister where he's out of proportion
not that Tom Cruise Tom Hanks yeah not
that like
he's not he's he's an a-lister he's
going to get on the red carpet he's a
big name people know the name but yeah
he's not on the cheap at the end of that
he seems to do projects He wants to do
and rather than projects that those
genre projects he's a genre actor it's
great but you can put them next to Vin
Diesel you can put him next to Dwayne
The Rock Johnson and people like that
and he's can hold his own all day but
when it's him
he like look his most recent projects
that he's done that are his projects
were C on Apple TV and Frontier on
Netflix those are very small projects
not not small projects but very small
comparative to awesome the things I
guess we're comparing them to
horrendously expensive projects
expensive yes uh was it like nine
million dollars an episode or something
it was really really expensive to me to
watch but in apple spin actually no I
don't think I think it's about 50
million dollars a series which actually
isn't that bad was it but I only did six
episodes didn't they so we're gonna
think I still haven't seen it um
it got better as it used to starts
really slowly but gets better okay
but but I think I do think that you've
got a point in that
for Stargate fans
this isn't going to be massively
exciting
because
something you mentioned
um so so your counter was Jay obviously
Ronan wasn't a vital character but Jason
Momoa is quite relevant and it's big
enough to bring in certain people I
don't think that's necessarily that
that's a good enough reason to do a Ron
index movie
because for the same reason where let's
for example say the kid who played in
the Frayer let's say he's now a massive
movie star
you're not going to do an Australia
movie because it doesn't make sense
I don't think it makes sense to make a
Ronan Dex movie
directed though wasn't he the problem
but that's that's my point just because
the person who made who played the
character is now
somewhat relevant more so than he was
when he played that character originally
doesn't is not a good enough reason to
make an entire movie about him
I I agree with you there but Ronan is
Mamoa aside Ronan Dex I think would be a
decent character because he is he's main
character enough I mean in in yeah Four
Seasons but also he kind of can bridge
the gap between multiple galaxies at the
same time and that I think is the the
biggest
biggest thing that I think he would
keep it simple stupid damn right sir
um
if he was if they were to make a Jason
Momo movie the only way it would make
sense if it was just as a Ronan Dex
movie it would to be to make it a
prequel and that would not excite me as
a Stargate fan no I don't think
well how else would they have Jason
Momoa be the main character and all
about have it be afterwards I would have
it that he's on
um I think I said this in my video I
would have he's on Earth he's basically
bored
so and he he wants us to go and Fight
The Wraith we refuse so he basically
says right I'm going and he leaves and
he goes back to the Pegasus we send him
through the Stargate whatever
then a lot of two-thirds of the movie
would basically be quite simple him just
fighting and then he finds that there's
a threat against the Earth and I would
like to see then the end of the movie
him returning to the SGC bringing in
some of those other characters bringing
in Shepherd bringing in McKay you know
having some of those characters in the
final third of the movie being them
fighting that or preventing whatever
that is attack against the Earth and
that's that's I don't think that I think
that's quite a simple story I could see
that ronadex would get frustrated if he
was stuck on the earth for too long
so I could see this believable and but
the main thing is I think for a wider
audience you don't need to have watched
Stargate Atlantis they could explain
that really easily in the storyline
um that with without going you know a
two-minute flashback thing at the start
of the film you explain it don't you
need to come to the races but it would
be an action movie going into your next
thing about it being a not a Stargate
film I think that's when you've got your
biggest point and I think you are
absolutely bang on this would be an
action film
it wouldn't be a Stargate movie
what is that necessarily a bad thing I
do like that idea that that that that
pitch that you just I like that idea but
I win no no
I wouldn't want that to be the thing
that kick-started the franchise because
I care I do care about Ronin as a
character I loved him as a character but
I care more about everyone else as a
collective and I want to know what
happened with everyone right rather than
just focusing on this one guy that's one
another I think big point that you make
it doesn't explain anything
you know that like the 15-year Gap it ex
this storyline really doesn't allow us
to explain anything
but is that again is that necessarily a
bad thing because this is a two-hour
advert for what follows
the series what we want is something
that's exciting popular gets people
talking
gets us the series that we want
then they can explain stuff
does it matter if they don't in the
movie if we get the series immediately
afterwards that we want
for me yes because I waited for so long
for Stargate to come back so I'm I'm
talking just as a fan and
if I if I I've been waiting this long
for a Stargate movie if they kick-start
it with this and it's not a Stargate
movie I'm gonna be bitterly disappointed
even if it's a fantastic movie I will be
so disappointed yeah
okay okay I'm trying to bridge the gap
between both y'all's things real quick I
think there's a way to do it and you
know damn well how I'm gonna do it is
Ronan is bored on Earth yes but he wants
to help us because we've helped him so
much over time and what is Ronan good at
he's he's good at fighting he's not
going to be allowed to go fight anywhere
on Earth so the Lucian Alliance is
probably still somewhere around I know
it's not the most popular thing in the
world but maybe ronan's been going
around maybe with like tilk or somebody
like that maybe some like other Jafar
Warriors who are not very particular
about the way Earth and and like all the
the powers that be handle things they're
like we need to actually go fight these
guys head on ronan's one of those people
that does that and of course the Lucian
Alliance is pissed off about that so
they get erisbach Jr or any Bounty
Hunter but airspock Jr please
to go after him
that would force him to go like run
essentially which might bring us back to
the Pegasus Galaxy might might do a
couple other things but you get hints of
15 years of Technology within that
and I think once ronan's gone people
like Taylor people like like Shepard and
McKay would want to probably go help him
even though
most of Stargate command probably
wouldn't be for that so maybe they have
to commandeer a ship might be a little
Star Wars they might have to say you
know what screw it we're just following
orders we're not following orders we're
gonna go help Ronan they go help Ronan
and of course they're probably talking
to sg1 at different points different
members from sg1 whatever Administration
position they may be in it's a way to
include everybody
kind of see where they're at without
overblind it without having them come in
under some savior in some moment or oh
this glorified Richard Dean Anderson
right here and that that'd be a way not
to kill off RDA right there either as
well
you you push the story and have people
go chase after Ronan who's on the run
again so yes we're getting back into
running
but he's not necessarily running he's
running from us and the Lucian Alliance
he's got bounty hunters it ropes
everything together in a way I don't
know I'm just I'm just thinking it's
spitballing I'm going to start the
killer RDA campaign I think the seasons
got die in this movie I think it'd be
awesome but um
I know that a lot of people don't want
that so um
[Laughter]
kill him
um
it took me a second to register what you
just said I thought you said don't kill
him and then and then it will kill him
yeah kill him no I knew Matt was gonna
be like no
um he he died in a blaze of glory and I
I want to see O'Neill die
because he's one of those characters
I've always said that right when I die I
want to make the papers I want it to be
like man steals a 90 year old man steals
Lamborghini
highest five beautiful girls and then a
Lamborghini and then goes through a gate
in a blaze of fire you know what I mean
and I want to go burning past Saint
Christopher in the Pearly Gates and fall
out and go right where are the girls
sort of thing and you know I want to be
in the papers
O'Neill should go out in a blaze of
glory in you know something that
deserves his thing because Richard E
Manson is quite an old man now he's not
going to be with us forever
let's get him while he's still young
enough to do something that would be
like deserve it of the character don't
let him don't let him dwindle away into
nothing don't let him you know die in
his sleep
but he causes you're saying as they're
having trouble figuring out someone to
actually authorize them chasing Ronin
Richard Dean Anderson as a general is
the only person who's like you know what
screw it we're going to take a small
little Force this way and I'm gonna lead
it and then he goes Hammond he goes
Hammond with us and we get that cool
little space kind of fight
[Applause]
a cowboy
um we'll come back to Richard Dean
Anderson because I want to talk about
the film that I think were actually that
I think we might be getting all right
and and from the from the rumors that
we've heard so we'll come back to that
but the last point you made was the big
like I said I think both of your points
are brilliant so far if you if you're
thinking about this as a gator but I
think if you think about this as an
executive I think actually the opposite
is true I think they don't necessarily
care about doing a star game that's my
worry that's my worry I don't want them
to think from an executive point of view
I want them to think and and try and try
and appease people who already are fans
of Stargate but all like I get that you
want new audiences but you can still do
that whilst making us happy yeah I think
everyone index music I think me when you
will walk out of the cinema and we'll go
[__] me that was amazing and you're
going I was a bit disappointed they
didn't do this because yeah but the
series starts in a month and you'll be
like yeah you know
everything I'm just disappointed about
will be sorted out in the series my
guard I just saw Ronan Dex beat up
whoever and you know it could be cool
anyway the big name thing though I
actually do think is a really good point
as well and I and I mean from all
perspectives on that because it does
increase
the expectation and it does increase the
budget I I agree with you hash he's not
a 20 or 30 million dollar a movie actor
but he's still a 10 million dollar he
got paid 10 million dollars for fast X
that's also a giant franchise I bet he
would go for five to eight that's just
that seems more I think he'd go for five
to the profits I think they could get
him full but it does increase
expectation
and um
so let's talk about the film sorry sorry
oh yeah I think that increases the risk
that we've talked about loads time that
if the film bombs it kills the franchise
dead there and then
and that's that's the risk we've always
talked about in it and if you've got
that so right so let's talk about what
we believe Amazon actually are going to
do so the rumors and and some things
that we know and some things we think
but
um the thing I was told
a year ago nine months ago was that they
actually had limited expectations for
the movie and they wanted the movie to
move straight into the series and they
weren't expecting this to be a 300 400
million dollar summer Blockbusters they
were expecting
um much you know basically Gators to go
and watch it
so somebody else speak to you no longer
basically said they're going to make a
move with the stargaters Picard season 3
proved that there is still an appetite
for that sort of thing and it's going to
be 40 something people that go nuts over
this and that we're the people that
still go to the cinema
kids done young people don't go to the
cinema it's 30 40 50 year olds that go
to the cinema Harris is literally the
only one that goes to the cinema
um yeah so he's basically said they will
make a Stargate movie and this is the
guy that told me the plan was to do a
Stargate sg1 Revival
right now that's what he said he said
there's no details on that because
there's no director there's no
the script we know is is still in
development whatever but
first of all if if that's if he's
accurate
and we're getting a Stargate sg1 Revival
which he said what do you think that
means
go on Harris you can think that well
okay I'll give you an option does that
mean we're going to be getting loads of
the sg1 actors back or does it just mean
it'll be an sg1 team and it'll be an
SG-1
style film as in a team going through
the gate
like that I wouldn't much prefer that
I'm gonna say something that's not very
popular
because I and I adore these freaking
actors I adore these actors
but none of them are film actors that's
not what their expertise in it's not
what their expertise have ever been in
and to to
put the franchise on their backs
in a big scale movie
I think is is
dangerous I don't think it's a good idea
at all no I I like I can say enough I
adore each and every single one of these
actors there's 17 seasons of television
with these guys plus more movies because
they're freaking great but they're not
film actors and it's a very different
thing and it's a very different thing
than a formulaic fun TV show because
this is gonna have to have a little more
gravitas as a film even their TV films
had a little more gravitas not a whole
bunch more necessarily but had a little
more gravitas to bring this back
properly it's gonna have to be more of
an action sci-fi film that's just the
way things are now and it's it's the way
they'd be playing into it and I don't
know even I
I don't know if Michael Shanks RDA a Man
attacking any of them would be right for
that honestly they they need to be I
guess more administrative roles or or
pushing that next SG-1 team forward just
yeah I I don't know if that's the
smartest route to take even though it
would feel great for our little hearts
for a moment
that might be all the moment we get if
that's the case not just that though if
they're going to have to have new people
there's always going to be a new people
a new team new people like
it's if they can still include the old
actors and it'll be a way of them
passing on the Baton to the new the new
team in a way that's satisfying for us
the same way
um
when Ben bradder for example when he
came into sg1
um as a leader
had RDA not been there and kind of like
this is your new leader like we might
have just been like who the hell is this
guy yeah like
it's that act of the actors give like
essentially giving their blessing kind
of thing that makes it satisfying for us
as the viewer
so I agree with you 100 with what you
just said but I just wanted to add that
no I think that makes perfect sense
we need that traditionally
you know I mentioned earlier and I
talked about this on the live yesterday
but traditionally the way to do this was
do Cinema movie and that seems to be
what Amazon are thinking about let's
kicked out the franchise with a cinema
movie because I think Jennifer saki
thinks that's still the way things work
since streaming services have come along
though and I honestly think things have
changed do you do we even think they
need to kick-start this with a cinema
movie
oh does it
I was in some ways is it a waste of time
and money
I've always been of the opinion that you
don't need to have a cinema movie you
could just go straight in with a series
I mean a movie is great and I'll be
happy if there was one and I'd still
watch it
but
I've always said at a series you can do
so much more and you can explain so much
more you could do like a slow burn
series
it doesn't have to explain everything
all in within an hour and a half you
could do things that explain little bits
here little bits there and have an
overarching story and that's I think for
me personally that's always a lot more
satisfying than watching a movie
yeah because you have to wait a week for
one you have to wait a week to see
what's going to happen next
um you might have
it might only be 10 or 12 episodes but
that's 12 hours worth of story compared
to one and a half hours and I think
that's the main thing
that I prefer you just get more
from it
and you look at things like stranger
things
like that did really well I'm not saying
stargate's going to do as well as as
what a stranger things does but people
will talk about new series when they
come out and more people will come in
and I think people talk about series
more than they do movies and don't
forget they showed strange things the
last series in cinemas
so the last couple of episodes in over
here they didn't know if they did in the
US or not but over here they showed a
few of them the day before in the cinema
because they were so popular and it
worked
um
going on from that Harris though right
so nowadays in particular and I think on
some films over a few years I always
think about think about
um Starship Troopers there was no decent
actors in that you could actually argue
that that the main actor whose name I
can't remember now
anyway can't act at all he is so wooden
and it is painful to watch him
um only
um the one guy and it was actually good
it was an awesome name I can't remember
anyway
um
there's no dish network they put all of
the money on the screen and made of just
a phenomenal movie
could they just do that with Stargate
does it matter and I was telling it and
I would argue that that's more true
today that you don't need big stars you
don't need a Jason Momoa in the movie
for it to succeed you just need it to
excite fans
does it matter
about the actors and whether they're TV
actors or not or known or whatever as
much anymore as it used to uh
he's God is the worst actor
I was looking up I was like well Neil
Patrick Harris classy Brown everybody
else is great it's got to be him uh it's
awful
you might have to give me the first part
of that question again but the the
second part at least
I I
I think it does matter if they're TV
actors or or film actors just because of
the way they're trained if they're
trained both ways that's fine and they
are similar enough particularly in how
TV's handled nowadays it's a lot more
film-like so I think that might help to
that degree
um but I still think they need film
actors it's just it's a very different
world and
yeah they're Bridging the Gap there but
I I would think they still need a film
actor over a TV actor I don't think they
should rely on TV actors or people that
have
specified in TV over decades to lead a
new film especially in a different era
of film this is I just wonder if the
um the lines have blurred
nowadays between the two and I think it
goes both ways film actors started
appearing streaming services but I think
it's it's blurred both ways I don't
think you need
those big actors anymore I think the
fact that it's a Stargate movie will
generate enough interest anyway they
don't need the Jason Momoa thing to
attract attention it's a Stargate movie
it will get attention
um
Nostalgia is a big thing and if they
bring a couple of the actors back but
also I'd quite like to be this this sin
if they're gonna do a cinematic movie
for me I like the Jason Momoa idea
because I love Jason Momoa for one
um but it would have to be a standalone
movie because they're not going to get
Jason Momoa in the series chances are
they might get him to do the odd episode
maybe but chances are he's not I'd like
the movie to be connected to the series
I don't want it to be constructed
so in that case you've got to have
actors that are willing to do the movie
but then do the series as well
I that would be that would be the way I
want to do this and again you don't have
to explain everything in the movie
but I want it to lead into the series
you know
um yeah whatever
and wouldn't that make more sense yeah
Denise church is just terrible on that
as well
[Music]
um I I think it makes
perfect sense
and there's a there's a lot to be said
for that but then if you're gonna do a
film with
I just I just it has to be actually I
think the film would have to be 10 times
as good as it would have to be if it was
a Ronan decks even oriented film or any
of the other characters because there
would be that Nostalgia bit if you're
just bringing the other characters back
as
pure Nostalgia and and you're relying on
new actors whether they're TV actors
film actors or whatever that's putting a
lot on these new guys back and a lot on
these new guys plate which which is good
they need to do that
but that's that's a lot because then the
other actors the old actors would
literally of course they might have
story points but it would feel like it
would just be for Nostalgia at that
point
um we we need a little something more
sound I think for him and
have it and that that's the thing Momoa
is
it's easy to go back to him partially
because he's not an Oscar actor he's he
literally in all of his movies he's more
of a TV actor than he is
a film actor still which plays too good
and bad traits of them and I just feel
like that fits more it's our
expectations wouldn't feel as high going
in if it weren't people that we knew
but going out our expectation or while
we were sitting there I think our
expectations would be 10 times as high
because it has to be something to draw
people in at that point and it's not
using anything to draw people in besides
Nostalgia I guess
huh
okay Matt is an idea then for you right
so we do an sg1 Revival
we get RDA we get Sam we maybe do that
idea that we suggested about
um I mentioned this on the video last
night as well we did that video about
the
um
there's a sect of global war the Court
members and they're trying to bring
Anubis back
um and that's the whole film is about
what's trying to stop them huh
would a film LED by Richard Dean
Anderson Amanda tappin Michael Shanks
Christopher Judge
with a new team as well on the side so
it's led by the original sg1 but in that
film they basically hand the Baton over
to a new team
would that
for one do you think it would be
successful at the cinema could it be
successful at cinema and two would that
tick all of your boxes from a Gator's
point of view
yes
somewhat
I um
I don't think that you can get a new
bits back because he's on the higher
plane of existence being fight by Omar
desala
and then it's so it splits them up while
they're fighting from a summer design
and that would release Osama I don't
think you understand how Ascension works
doesn't understand our Ascension Works
touche
okay but I don't think it's very easy
just to write some sort of if there's
some sort of magic ancient machine that
can draw in ascended being that would be
so peace
well I mean they did it with the aura I
didn't know there's a machine that can
just kill ascended beings oh how
convenient
yeah
I left it behind the sofa oh
the ascent of being killing machine
no no actually
that could work because that kills
that kills ascended beings and Anubis
was half ascended
they killed the Ancients obadasara is
fully I said oh
so no half of them is bad
and it just pulls his body of course his
being back into a body or something an
Anubis magnet
um no no no ignore the magnet we're
talking about the the Ascender killer
now I know but then it would freak yeah
I I get that yeah yeah okay use that one
however they do it and how have they
decided to do it you know they will take
up a perfectly logical way of doing that
and then they will think up some Cinema
way of doing it that will all go what
why does that work but anyway it doesn't
matter however they do it they're trying
to release Anubis they're trying to get
Anubis back that's the point of the
movie and then
um but it's the the point of the old sg1
team and a new sg1 team I I could see
that an sg1 team so that's we see the
program as it is now and there's an sg1
team but because of what's going on they
need the knowledge of the original sg1
team to come back and it's a bit like um
I mentioned yesterday Top Gun and
Maverick are they need that those people
with the knowledge to come back and help
the younger inexperienced team who have
never even fought the goal of all don't
forget they won't have even they would
never have fought the gold at that point
um and I just think that's that would be
a really cool and I think it would be
but if you've never watched Stargate you
wouldn't have a freaking clue what was
going on yeah
uh and there's another thing Maverick is
an ensemble film
it's following Tom Cruise one of the Old
Guard would this film be following one
of the Old Guard or would it be
following one of the new guard and is
the new guard a team of four or is it
just like another
uh Joe Flanagan like Like a Shepherd
situation and we find the team along the
way
I wouldn't mind if it was just one
person and like the new but that's the
thing if the new guards in there or if
the old guards in there
and they're leading them to some big
something I think the only way to handle
that is to kill off a bunch of them
honestly and I don't want to kill off a
bunch of SG-1 but if it's if it's an sg1
movie and you're introducing new sg1
that's that's a lot well it immediately
goes from four people to eight people if
you do another sg1 team
so and that's that's a lot of money
that's a lot of actors
because of the way Stargates worked
historically they they've just moved up
the ranks and now they were in
administration positions where you don't
see them on screen as often but at this
point ever at all again at this point
how are they going to go up we've had
them been with them for 15 years they're
all going to be generals they're all
going to be Admirals they're all going
to be these freaking huge things there's
not going to be anywhere else would be a
general we know that um some would be a
general Watcher might not necessarily be
in Stargate command we'd hope she is
Jack is obviously now a retired General
um will be a draft for somewhere leading
Jaffa probably yeah and Michael Shank oh
sorry Daniel Jackson would be
um maybe the the the the what the
non-government program leader of SGC or
something yeah the SGC maybe it's his
idea that to bring
so whatever it was would have to be
related to an episode in Stargate sg1
so that could be a planet they've been
to a mission they've been on something
it would have to be something specific
that you have to bring them back
you know what I mean because they know
how to get through you know this
this isn't this isn't what they do but
it's there's a maze the story is the
maze they have to get through and only
the original unless you want to know how
to get through it I'm not being
literally I'm being you know like
the only issue you want to know how to
get from A to B on this job so they have
to bring them in to do it and it could
be Daniel who's the civilian leader of
the scene there's no's there's this we
need Jack
and we need Sam and we need to look
you know
um and that's right and sg1 you're gonna
have to take them but another problem is
though
isn't that a film we've seen a million
times it's a film we've seen a million
times and if they don't kill people off
people are going to be pissed off at the
end because it's going to feel like
nothing happened it's Space Cowboys
isn't it with Clint Eastwood and think
that's maybe that's where I'll get this
idea from so watch Space Cowboys about a
month ago
great movie you know you've got the
young astronauts and they need the older
astronauts because they're the only ones
who know to do it and boom um but
that's not a bad thing because I mean
virtually every film or series you've
that's ever been made you can go over
it's very similar to something else that
came before written oh yeah
so that's not necessarily A Bad Thing
it's a trident that's a good thing about
Stargate is if you do kill off every
single character from before they can
still come back because they have the
Multiverse
and they've got Daniel Jackson yeah
he died was it six times something like
that it's something like six
so
but I and then and I'd kill off RDA if
rda's in this movie right I will tell
you right now I will put 50 pounds at
any charity you wish if he survives
um I know that'd be awesome but um like
I said I don't want to see him die but
it's not what we want or what what was
cool sometimes what we need is not
always what we want
same like like Harrison Ford with Han
Solo I'm pretty sure anything RDA would
come back with in sg1 or Stargate in
general he'd just be like kill me kill
me off please kill me kill me kill me
kill me kill me it would be begging them
until they did kind of deal
you know yeah but the difference is
Richard D Anderson likes star okay he's
not as massive Starfire fan but he liked
working on Stargate Richard Harrison
Ford hated Star Wars those last couple
reasons though
yeah he did he liked the paycheck I
think I think he's been quite honest
about that
RDA wasn't the biggest fan in the last
couple seasons though so maybe a little
bit of that bad taste because he I mean
he came back with SGU and a little bit
SGA but like
every interview
the only reason he left us because he
wanted to spend more time with his
daughter he didn't have much time
because she was growing up so he left
Carrie please please thank you so much
for the contribution Kerry we absolutely
adore you thank you so much and please
God stay safe
another one yeah
yeah
in in the east coast of Canada like
really
apparently the water gets warm enough
for that
that's not good
Joseph malozey
seriously Carrie please please stay safe
and let us know you're right once it's
all passed and all cleared up yeah
um and thank you for the contribution
really really appreciate it
um
see that's the thing is just the one
thing
that I think we talked about yesterday
again but I'd love to know your opinion
Stargate is such a massive universe
and there's so many possibilities
as long as they keep the movie
reasonably simple
because you have to be a complete [__]
to screw this up
oh no I think it's way easier to screw
up than actually get right I think I
think it is way 99 easier to screw up
than it would be to get it right but I
think there are a few different Avenues
they could take to get it right and I
they're not blatantly obvious but if you
think about it they're they're there and
honestly the Ronin little thing is a way
they could do it that's that's one of
those Avenues but
would it be popular overall would it is
it enough to bring Stargate people back
versus new audience is it enough to
bring in a new audience versus Stargate
audience and there are other things you
have to gauge and you're gonna have to
gauge those things with each one of
those Avenues but I think there are a
few tributaries off the river that would
be the clear path to take here
um where everywhere else is just going
to lead you to another little river bank
or something and um yeah you're done for
my metaphor there
all right so
I I want a Stargate movie
I don't want a Ronan Dex movie to
kick-start it although I do want to ruin
the next movie at some point
um
so everything I've said
is with the caveat of not yet
I want it not yet it needs to start off
as something more
true to what Stargate was originally
next movie I don't think is true to what
stock it was originally because as Jay
said it would just be an action movie
let's have a day in the life of Walter
so he goes in he gets it start off with
his breakfast
right and it ends with him going to bed
it literally ends with him putting his
head down and it's just everything that
goes on during the day
come on you've you've leaned back and
you obviously look very angry at me
right now well come on you'd want to see
that film
no I wouldn't that have been the most
boring film ever
well it wouldn't because of all the
stuff that would happen but
no
I want the main characters Walter's a
great character but he's a side
character leave him on the side
seriously though you know how they
should announce
the Stargate you know because I mean
there was rumors
that weren't true that there was a
little
um
video put together how they're going to
announce this
all they need is Walter oh let me check
his name I can't remember his real name
I do know his name because it's Joe
Smith Jones
excuse me Gary Jones
all they need is Gary Jones and he just
and it's just him at a computer and he's
just gotta go Chevron seven locked and
they have the sound effects sort of
thing
SDC you know at San Diego Comic-Con or
something and then they bring on a
couple of the actors and we go yep we're
doing a movie or a series or whatever
the hell they decided to do because with
his strikes you never know that much
change completely
that's all they have to do for me garage
Gary Jones
done
and we'd go crazy I agree with that I
agree with that yeah it would be the
coolest way to announce
the the what they're intending to do
that'd be great him and is it Paul
mcgillian is that how you say his name
right uh
um well Beckett Beckett yeah yeah they
have them they have a podcast together
which is hilarious and they're they're
well I've not seen that yeah I know Gary
Johnson this past week and it's it's so
it's simple but it's hilarious
um right I I did not know that so I've
been trying to get in touch with Gary
Jones actually I know somebody that
knows him and I've been trying to get in
touch with him and I'd love to get him
on the show if we can so maybe that's an
Avenue to go come on the show and
advertise your podcast
with us
I'll try I'll try again to get him on
I'll I'll explore I never I didn't try
the um I didn't try back it so maybe we
need to go that way
um okay
and we can all cry together about the
fact that he died
ish
Jesse came back
he did the episode Grace well he did die
it was a clone that came back right this
club came back yeah yeah that would that
was the saddest episode ever
it was it was even sadder it was Heroes
when Janet died
Heroes when
um oh was it here what's his name
episode
when a doctor thingy died in this she
won his name is yeah
I've got a really stinking headache by
the way at the moment so my brain's not
working as quickly is it normal the
reason I think
um Sunday from Atlantis is sadder than
that was because of this speech at the
end between uh Beckett and um okay
bring maxilla and Walter silent and
Walter and lots of Ronan guns knows that
I agree that they can't bring the penis
gun back I'm afraid
um I I liked the penis gun it's actually
talking about this that we started
talking about butt plugs
that was Frank versus Russia It's Always
Sunny just go back to It's Always Sunny
oh yeah of course it was anyway they
can't bring back the penis gun no stormy
is not even here and spark plugs have
been put up I didn't say anything
me and stormy are clear this week
sci-fi Quest thank you so much for the
contribution really appreciate it
um so but yeah knows that stumbling is
that back
um
they do like I wrote about the world
I joke about the Walter movie
would we hate it though if we brought
back if it was a movie that wasn't
a big sci-fi movie
if it was a character-driven
you know I mean I I joke about the wall
to idea thing but if it wasn't if it
wasn't a spaceship in sight he wouldn't
be necessarily the right character to do
but
[Music]
that's what Stargate has always been I
think going big is a bad idea a a
terrible idea we need somewhere to go
you know just talk it doesn't need
spaceships
it never has needed spaceships
it has spaceships
um because I think the story called for
it later on but they've been there since
the beginning
not really apart from Attack festivals
you've got a gold get anywhere only the
Asgard get anywhere
yeah but we do most of the stories are
90 of the
storyships
but where we are now
anyway sorry keep going keep going
that's my point
we did spaceships to begin with it
I would disagree with that I think
spaceships have inherently been part of
Stargate since the movie like literally
the whole thing figuring it out that it
doesn't need them is what I mean 90 of
Stargate is not set around there's no
spaceships that's inherently false just
because of Stargate Atlantis and
Stargate Universe those are literally
but but I'm on about the beginning at
the beginning
but if we're doing an sg1 Revival of any
sorts why wouldn't they be using puddle
jumpers right now why why wouldn't I
mean there's
and we can do that without getting it
star Trekkie I know that's the thing
like we don't want it to feel like Star
Trek or anything like that but literally
it already doesn't feel like Star Trek
because they've used more than one ship
so we're okay
um
I don't know I feel like they are
inherently part of Stargate and and
there's just this
it's nothing you're gonna get rid of so
you might as well lean into it but not
necessarily make it
pivotal pivotal pivotal like it was an
SGU per se because I did
kind of sway people away from it to a
degree yeah I'm just wondering that it's
my thinking is is Go Back to Basics and
have somewhere to
build from
from the series as well when we get the
series
Focus back on an sg1 team Focus back on
going through things and and and slowly
they've got 15 years of stuff to tell us
about as well don't try and do it all at
once do it nice and slowly tease things
you know like hinted things it gives you
way more places to go you've got not
only if they got loads of story to tell
us about what's going on like I said
they've got 15 years of stuff to tell us
they've got so many stories to tell
I just think but the worst thing they
can do is if they try to rush it
um but I do think they need to do the
Marvel way of doing it and they kept
saying this didn't they always I've been
saying this for two years nearly that
Amazon want to do a marvel-esque type
thing there was movies TVs the brilliant
Thing Marvel did was they started
reasonably slowly and they steadily
built that up over time just a second
sorry sgts need more electronic buggies
quad bikes and mini drones yes let's not
have missions where you're limited by
walking distance that would be great
um and what's the nth space seed
equivalent into sg1 episodes what's
what's in the space seed equivalent to
SG episodes I'm not quite sure BK what
you mean guys
not positive
thank you very much for the contribution
thank you give us another don't pay for
it yeah I'll have a look and and tell us
what you mean sorry I mean it's an
episode of Star Trek from the original
series
what's space seed is that on all them it
doesn't sound good I don't know I don't
know other than Star Trek
tell us in a second
um I'll come back to DK I promise
um
James rice spaces again I've got a
headache so I'm not my brain isn't
working very well but I'm not following
that I'm sorry
um
space seed star
Trek Khan
thingy device the Genesis device
they're talking about the Genesis device
from Star Trek traffic on
there wasn't one in um in it's a it's a
um it was a missile that landed on the
planet and basically terraformed the
planet instantly
I don't know anyway not sure
space seed was a living ship
so
just just while we've mentioned the Star
Trek stuff and obviously we don't want
it to turn into Star Trek but there is
so there are things set up technically
that we could go to Stargate the Next
Generation or something along those
lines would you rather an SG-1 team that
doesn't have to deal okay just riddle me
this just a movie about an sg1 team but
it is like a hand maybe sg1 is the one
like unit that's kind of like that lead
unit that is highly specified and of
course there's plenty of other SG teams
doing their thing but sg1 is like you
know it's it's the pretty units it's the
one that they bring out to to go talk to
everybody it's the one that they use to
kind of uh bring that uh uh
camaraderie with everybody
so in the thought process of that maybe
they would have used
Sam and Jack's kid if they had one or
Val and Daniel's kid if they had one
maybe Jack's clone as well maybe uh uh
kid leads it
is that two on the nose
have not joined sg1 he is such an idiot
I don't love the idea I'm just thinking
about it while we're while the Star Trek
was on the mind I think that's that's
too far and it's a terrible idea
but let's be honest it's probably what
they do
and because for some reason
they seem to think they have to keep
telling us the old stories or they have
to bring back characters as the son of
whoever or and that
because that's the only way these things
work isn't it no it's not that's not how
real life works at all I the only thing
I think is because Hollywood is so
inbred
um that you know they actually a lot of
the stars are even even like everyone
talked about how oh my God they talked
they've met 6 000 kids before they um
decided that Daniel Radcliffe was going
to be Harry Potter and it turns out his
mom and dad are casting directors
and I'm like well
why are you telling us about the 6 000
kids because you obviously then just
picked somebody you knew
and how often do you see about movie
stars and you find out that their dad's
a movie star that dancer director or
that you know what I mean it's like it's
quite an inbred little sense with every
industry on this planet though
and I'm not trying to just be biased
with woo Hollywood
so um but that's the other thing I think
it's so important maybe I think how they
how they think the real world is but um
I I would hate that idea I think it'd be
awful
um
and and but they do it a lot in the new
Quantum Leap it's Sam's kid that's the
what are you doing
I was wondering the same thing I was
sounds awful and it looks weird
in a minute
[Laughter]
um bad Matthew
um right so
um I I'd hate that if they did that um
but you could do a Next Generation with
just new characters and bring back a few
of the old ones as you know is thinking
but that's what I would love to see I
think
um it's like a Next Generation but
keep it simple for me all day keep it
simple
we'll end where we we started keep it
simple stupid
and that's the way I think to go and if
that was a rolling Dex movie because
they decided to bring you know the only
A-list star back as long as they brought
back
Joe Flanagan David Hewlett as well
that's that's another thing is
I don't think we should focus on
watching sg1 when when
it does feel like they've there they are
just that much more removed than even an
SGA cast and
the SGA cast has gone on to do I guess
almost as memorable as things
uh
I don't know it's just
I I would feel bad having only sg1 there
and then only SGA so maybe it's a good
idea to not bring back any of them in
the movie and explore that in
the TV series or or a multitude of TV
series whatever they end up doing
I don't know I I just I'm scared with
how much they're going to rely on
Nostalgia for the film and I feel like
that can fit in a TV series more
uh purposefully because they can be
meticulous about it and actually make
sure the storylines fit where in a film
if they just try to get as many
characters in that thing as possible
it's it's
we might end this we we might end these
two years of tops just as quickly as I
started kind of deal you know I don't
think the mistake isn't it I think
um is that if you if they try to go this
is what I'm trying to say as take your
time if they try and go too fast
too quickly that's when I think they'll
ruin it if they don't tell us too much
about what's going on last 15 years too
quickly that's when they're ruin it and
it's what DC in the last 10 years of
that's the mistake they've made over and
over again try to throw everything
into that one movie we don't need it
they want to serve I would much rather
have them tease things that were going
to come so though there's lots of
threads that we we want answers to maybe
they can like reference it and then just
never mention it after that and then
we're in our heads we're like okay
they've mentioned it here so they
they're good they know about it they're
gonna do it at some point but that's way
more satisfying I think
it's like it's like with the flash
um when The Flash TV show there was like
storylines that were
in the comics and it was getting to like
seasons
five six five and six and we're like
this guy's got to come in it at some
point and they kept referencing these
people like godspeed and things like
that and then eventually they came into
it and it was incredibly satisfying if
they do that
I'll be on board with that yeah
obviously don't bring godspeed into
Stargate it's a completely different
franchise
well they could do those little Speedy
things again you know it's always an
option I do have a little something to
end the video and that we're just going
to talk about quickly because
um I spoke to one of my friends
yesterday and it did tell me something
interesting that makes absolutely no
sense but we'll talk about it briefly
but here we go
[Music]
I don't know why I like it two weeks ago
there was a PR meeting that one of the
people I speak to was satin the
um
Claudia valentini's office had sent a
memo basically talking about the RoboCop
movie
um Stargate movie and um the Legally
Blonde movie and the basic comment was
that Stargate is supposed to be out
um in uh spring 2025
um Legally Blonde three was supposed to
be out
um summer next year 2024 and they want a
Robocop
I know I'm changing the channel Legally
Blonde three Trek of course and they
want RoboCop by the summer of 2025.
um you're telling us they're combining
all the franchises together and it's
going to be an MGM verse the point being
they were then asked they would then as
part of this this meeting they were
talking about how do they have they been
when do they start the promotion work
blah blah and somebody did point out
well surely we're pushing all this
timelines back
um and so they met about so this that
was the response to the the the memo
from Claudia Valentini surely we're
putting all these things back because in
strikes the response from Claudia
Valentina was one word why
and that was how this response I'm sure
there was more than that to the thing
but that was that's basically I was
paraphrased to me
Amazon do not see why any of the strikes
changed that timeline
so it would still be a Stargate movie in
Spring of 2025 RoboCop in the summer and
obviously Legally Blonde three
in the summer of um 2024
one respect
yay two
is Amazon is this something wrong with
Amazon or do we really not know
something
because the pr company that was involved
in this they're talking about they are
just they were just asking
what is the time frame when do we start
we need to plan how do we promote these
things so they're nothing to do with the
creative they don't know what's being
made they don't know what stage it's at
they don't know any of that stuff they
don't need to know they're just
basically when do we do our job
that's what they're asking
and Amazon have told them the time frame
isn't changing
what do you think that means if anything
are we getting International stuff
Rangers immediately we already think it
might be being filmed in Eastern Europe
if the Stargate yeah RoboCop could very
easily be filmed in um oh sorry just a
second I finally won furlings yes evil
Ewoks will be in this movie if it kills
me and if they're not in this movie I am
personally going to kick Jennifer sarki
in the furling say veronin
yeah thank you so much again for the
Matt just like
everyone's in
I'm not doing the captain came I think
but Matt does that mean anything or is
it just Amazon
having the rumors of things being seen
in like the likes of Poland and stuff
like that already
are they just circumventing America at
this point
like they just they the strikes are
happening and they're just like [__] it
we'll go somewhere else
[Music]
they're not circumventing America
they're circumventing one company One
Union that's it maybe two unions they're
not circumventing us as a country even
it's literally just two unions that are
causing all of this and yeah and that's
making me sound anti-union but I I I'm
over it at this point all my friends
like I'm I'm in this freaking City and
we're all trying to work
do something they're yeah the studios
aren't exactly correct on everything but
neither are the writers and neither are
the actors
same thing we're doing every night okay
we're gonna take over the world
but yeah I like that that person's
picture looks like one of Pinky and I
know it's a cat these look like a bit
like pinky
I
I'm not sure what to make
of that information I didn't want it I'm
not doing a video on it because I don't
think it's big enough but I thought it's
worth talking about on here
um
that could just be Amazon basically
saying look there's plenty of time the
strike's gonna be you know the strike's
not going to go forever we're sticking
to this at the moment until we farmed it
could just be that or it could be
they know something we don't
I mean that could be the case there's
also
I don't see them necessarily going
around but they could go completely
non-union there are many companies that
have done some some really good films
that are non-union films and
they could go non-union which would
possibly change the landscape of film
and and TV and the way it's considered
in the US to a degree because if it's
some big
franchise like like Stargate coming back
and doing that why not
I'm blonde it doesn't look like
yeah I started blonde when I was a baby
if you're blonde
I um
our Spock
I mean I'm in the dark right now hold up
yeah okay there's nothing but blonde
it's a little dirty but it ain't
Browning and black it ain't red
it's a bit Brown it looks Brown
I've been inside you need to get some um
you need to get some highlights in there
I'm blonde anyway what are you talking
about
um very light up there I got a forehead
of hand not fat as well I'm I'm six-pack
it's under again in the fridge I was
literally
yeah
um Harris is illegally blunt damn right
sequel I know I've been campaigning for
Eris block Jr but give me a Legally
Blonde spin-off there we go we'll call
it strawberry Bond illegally blonde
strawberry
something I don't know especially with
Star Trek episode into intro to Khan uh
uh I don't remember that I don't
remember the original series episode
keep them up right so I know what he's
talking about though now I think so what
is this Star Trek equivalent to that
episode that neither of you will have
watched because you're not Star Trek
fans I have watched it I know I know
exactly what the original series I
literally said it was it was the Star
Trek original series episode when he
said it but the actual one with Khan in
though the original yes
what would be the equivalent episode of
that in Stargate then
um
I would say anything with like Ascension
so
if you've got
um
oh
the
the episode where they went to uh what's
that planet called chem
yeah
when they first met the um the when they
first met him
yeah the heart CC's they were looking
for the heart easy child yeah yeah
I would say the first time we saw
replicators because they went on to
become
one first time we saw Anubis or the
first time Anubis was hinted
because we didn't see him at first did
we we heard about him a couple of times
and then so that would be a good one
um
I don't want to go with you all right
because that basically just went into
the start of season nine didn't it yes
the aura is just Ascension just
bad guys so we already knew about that
so I would say for me I think the
equivalent is the first time we see the
replicators
because I actually think that's when
Stargate jumped to another level
um but it wasn't just about the gold and
it became a much bigger universe
um and then it led into
some of the best Stargate episodes even
though I was never a massive fan of the
villain I'm sure you're right because
the first time we see the replicators
wasn't the replicators that eventually
tried to take over the Galaxy it was the
um the replicators made by that robot
girl yeah yeah
so yeah I I would agree with that yeah
and then you've got that three-parter's
episode so when um I would actually I'm
actually thinking about the three-parter
when
um
uh the Asgard came down and basically
said we've got this enemy that we can't
defeat we then saw the anneal and we
then saw the Russian sub episode and
that was a three thousand three parties
when I think that's the first time we
saw the actual replicators spiders and I
think that's when that that's what I'm
talking about how Stargate went on to a
different level for me I remember
watching those episodes go in this isn't
just a Sci-Fi show anymore this is my
new obsession
this this is one of this is probably the
greatest Sci-Fi show ever made this is
just
this is this got stratospheric for me
now it's not just good this is amazing
sort of thing um so I think maybe that's
it for Me Maybe
so many
episodes though that just took it to
another level and then they just kept
finding another gear in that downstairs
so just make it get better and better
but um
okay
I forgot what we were talking about
before we talk about that we're talking
about something else before I forgot and
then something I don't know let's call
it a night anyway guys thank you so so
much I've been brilliant as always
everybody in the comments you've have
some absolute beauts and thank you for
any contributions again it really helps
the channel out so thank you so so much
um and we've got to pay for a Comic-Con
thank you very little helps
um so yeah you use the money gives the
money gives them money it's all gone
into a nice bank account so me and
Matthew can maybe go to Comic-Con next
year
um
we will we will I'm going I've already
told the wife I'm just like no woman I'm
going
please if you wouldn't mind
um I'll buy you something pretty so
um but yeah no I think I think she's
okay here we go
um so thank you so much guys
um next week we'll talk about something
non-start get related if we can be
bothered or it'll be Stargate again no
I'm sure we'll think of something
different don't pull a face anyways
other things other than about getting
this world
um
Doctor Who because next week if any of
you are Doctor Who fans they they posted
on Instagram like I think actually they
might tweeted it it was a picture anyway
and it was all binary and that binary
translated to a trailer happening next
Saturday so if that happens
hmm
we can talk about that
that's that's the first three minutes of
the um episode sorted and learn we'll
figure I I think we just have a hangout
next week guys should we have a summer
hangout so we'll talk about Doctor Who
we'll talk about whatever else we've
seen that week we'll just have a hangout
we'll just chill out no major topic
we'll just just saying you guys can
bring your comments and you know what
you want to talk about as well and we'll
we'll just have a hangout next week
unless something crazy happens between
now and then
and then we'll like a doctor who trailer
it's gonna have to be good
um okay
just a second I got a question captain
um question Jay since he didn't mention
it yesterday when did Sam ever mention
MacGyver I've seen sg1 countless of
times repeatedly and don't recall that
more than once so in the first couple of
episodes she was talking about how she
macgyvered the um at the SGC basically
the computer system replaced the
um because they don't have a dial Home
device they don't have a DHD so they had
to MacGyver the computer system
um didn't they mention MacGyver in the
Antarctic episode as well
that's that's a blooper but yeah yeah
that's just the blooper which is the
best freaking blooper of starting I've
seen the scenes that's why it's in my
head and I think it was mentioned again
later but I can't remember when but I
think I think Daniel mentioned MacGyver
or something
but anyway the memory one was in the
first couple of episodes when she's
talking about how they got the computer
system to they MacGyver it
um so yes so yeah that blooper is the
best though we've got MacGyver I'm a
gadget mcuseless whatever she says it's
perfect I love it so much yeah it is
awesome so
um there you go then so there you go
answer but um yeah the blooper was the
second time but she did she did 100 say
in the episode
and I I think it was the second episode
third episode it was very early on in
the series anyway right
bye bye everybody we'll see you next
week have fun be safe everybody and guys
just
bye bye see y'all
foreign
[Music]